all right so we're going to be at 9 30
i'm going to get open up the
committee to study medical intervention
and immunizations
we're going to again start with a pledge
of allegiance the flags over there
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
thank you
so one of the things that i i want to
bring attention as we start this meeting
is to make everybody uh so everyone's on
the same page
there are 33 lsrs filed relative to four
topics
relative to covid masks mandates or
vaccinations
i'm going to run through a quick list
it's a little boring but i'm going to
run just run a list of the titles of
those bills so people are aware of what
bills are potentially upcoming and it
may later not relate to your testimony
so i'm just writing these down numerical
order as i searched them on on
the general court website the first bill
title is relative to requiring coven 19
vaccination for school attendance
requiring the new hampshire attorney
general to empower a coven 19 grand jury
to investigate the events related to the
kovit 19 pandemic
relative to state grants for research
and the effects on the human body of the
covid19 vaccines
eliminating
never mind scratch that one
requiring post-secondary institutions to
accept religious and medical exemptions
from vaccine requirements requiring an
audit of the new hampshire vaccine
association
making a state vaccine registry an
opt-in program
relative to the exemptions from vaccine
mandates relative to the exemption from
school vaccine mandates relative the
student attendance in public schools
that mandate the wearing of face masks
without an emergency order in place
limiting the authority of the department
of health and human services to mandate
vaccinations and relative to quarantine
costs
relative to state enforcement of federal
vaccine mandates
relative to the medical mandates adopted
by employees
relatives employee protections from
covet 19 in the workplace
prohibiting state and local governments
from adopting certain mandates in
response to covet 19 and prohibiting
employers in places of public
accommodations from discriminating on
the basis of vaccine status
relative to procedure of withdrawing
from the vaccine registry
requiring the department of health and
human services to maintain certain
recons records relative to the vaccine
registry
expanding the prohibition against
discrimination based on the individual's
election not to participate in the state
vaccine registry
prohibiting the department of health and
human services from requiring vaccine
passports for services
prohibiting higher education
institutions
from receiving state funds from
from requiring face mass and kobe night
vaccines for for attendance
proclaiming monday
march
the first monday of march is the coven
19 victims and survivors memorial day
relative to the limited liability for
personal injury resulting or related to
exposure from covid19
relative to unemployment benefits for
employees terminated for refusing to
comply with vaccine mandates
relative to the unenforceable
relative to unenforceability of
non-compete agreements upon termination
of employee for non-compliance for the
vaccine mandate
relative to vaccine mandates and
government contractors
relative financial responsibility for
employer mandated coven 19 testing of
employees
prohibiting a school district from
mandating covert vaccinations for school
attendance prohibiting certain employees
from requiring covet vaccination as a
condition of employment
relative to the eligibility of workers
compensation for adverse reaction to the
mandatory to a mandatory covenant
vaccination
requiring food and drug administration
approval of all vaccines relative to
covid19 health and safety policies
at new hampshire performing arts venues
relative the school district policies on
facial mass for student schools students
in schools
requiring an independent audit and
assessment regarding covenant team
preparedness
at long-term care facilities nursing
homes in new hampshire veterans home and
make an appropriation therefore
so those are on my quick search all the
bills that we have that are currently
going to be heard
in the legislature
um the goal of this committee is not
necessarily evaluating those bills
however
what we're looking for is the
intersection
of shall and shall nots in either state
law or agency rules that as it relates
to medical intervention immunizations
so as a former police officer i know
there are certain roles of government
that are that are appropriate so i i and
medical intervention is appropriate so
as a former police officer i use the
idea of an iea
right so there are times when a person
suicidal and this police mandate that
they get they commit them to get
treatment to to make sure they don't
hurt themselves so uh we use the uh fire
department with narcan in an overdose
situation we can use um an inmate in the
in the prison who gets stabbed and is
refusing medical attention brexit
enforcement medical care we're gonna
stitch that person that inmate up so we
know that there are certain roles in uh
of government that are appropriate and
where medical intervention is
appropriate and given certain
circumstances the problem is i'm not
omnipotent and the committee's not
omnipotent we don't know where all of
those intersections are and the goal for
this meeting is to bring out some of
that information so the committee can
can evaluate uh those intersections and
in state law or agency rules um to see
if they're appropriative see if there's
they need strengthening or maybe they
need to be weakened or maybe nothing
needs to be done with them so that's the
kind of thing i think the committee is
looking for and i'll open up the
committee members if they want to make
any other comment before we start taking
information from the people anybody
erica you're good uh erica leon is here
she's replacing uh herschel nunes uh who
wasn't it was unable to attend
great all right first up erica who we
got
first up we have ann edwards from the
attorney general's office
good morning
i'm ann edwards from the attorney
general's office
i'm
really here more to answer questions and
you might want me to answer questions
after some of the agencies speak
since they're the ones who know their
own statutes better
in looking at the invitation that was
provided to the group
there were some specific questions
i can't answer all the questions of
where the shells and the shall nots are
i'd be happy to talk them through
clearly as you just said representative
lang if there are shells in the law we
have to follow them for the most part
oftentimes in those same statutes there
are some exceptions or there is case law
that has developed exceptions to those
shalls and if there are shall nots we
have to follow those as well
and it's the same
provisions that are available sometimes
to modify what that shall not means in
certain circumstances
with respect to the question of the
definition of medical intervention
interestingly that phrase itself shows
up once in new hampshire law
and it shows up in
the
statute rsa 415 dash capital d colon 3
which is the definition section of the
long-term care insurance act
could you repeat that rsa sure it's rsa
dash roman capital d
poland
thank you and then the specific
provision is
roman five
in the middle of a very long paragraph
that defines long-term care insurance
and in that
statute it provides that with regard to
life insurance this term does not
include life insurance policies that
accelerate the death benefit
especially
for specifically sorry for one or more
of the qualifying events of terminal
illness medical conditions requiring
extraordinary medical intervention or
permanent institutional confinement and
that provide the option of a lump sum
payment for those benefits
so that's the only place in new
hampshire law where the phrase exists
as a result if
the this committee would like to suggest
a definition of the term medical
intervention i think
the path is wide open for you to do that
when
so in
the law when we are looking for how to
define a term or how to define
a phrase
and the courts are looking at that we
all go to the dictionary and so one of
the places to regularly start with that
is the merriam-webster dictionary which
is where
i proceeded and that they do not have
the specific phrase
medical
intervention as a definition there
they do have the phrase the the word
intervention
and that word is defined as the act or
fact of taking action about something in
order to have an effect on its outcome
and they further on in the online
version go into an explanation of
medical intervention as
the act or fact or a means of
interfering
with the outcome or course especially of
a condition or process
as to prevent harm or improve
functioning and so then they start
talking about using specific examples
such as
mitral
valve replacement
in order to deal with a condition so
it's and then when you look at other
definitions i went to places like the
national institutes of health under the
national cancer institute under that
definition in medicine
intervention intervention is a treatment
procedure or other action taken to
prevent or treat disease or to improve
health in other ways
and then there are many more medical
dictionaries out there one of the
broadest definitions that i found
was that intervention in medicine means
anything meant to change the course of
events for a person surgery
a drug a test a treatment counseling and
providing informational pamphlets
so that's about the broadest definition
that i could find and so i think what
that shows you is
how you define the term medical
intervention in new hampshire law will
be what it applies to
the
one challenge with defining that term
too broadly is to make sure that
you're not sort of catching provisions
of the law that you don't mean to
interfere with
by preventing in a certain way and so
when you look at house bill 220
on lines
starting on line 10 which is the shall
not provision of house bill 220 and all
the things that house bill 220 doesn't
implement
many of these are those provisions that
we would
suggest that you be cautious of
and aware of in in defining medical
intervention the first is the
commissioner of health human services
ability to order quarantines and to
order treatment for communicable
diseases
the second is the requirements under
current new hampshire law for
vaccination prior to admission to school
or child care agencies
the third is the involuntary emergency
admission process
and the involuntary treatment of
patients
the fourth is
to not limit treatment authorized by
guardians or surrogates or individuals
who hold a durable power of attorney
the fifth is that it doesn't apply to
nursing homes the state hospital or any
other medical facility operated by the
state or by one of the political
subdivisions
and then in the next roman numeral
section it also excludes the department
of corrections for any
medical treatment or immunization that's
required there so those are some of the
specific areas
the
depending on how broadly you define the
term you could find that you also
come into situations where there are
mandatory examinations before an
individual can hold a job
so for example airline pilots have to
have an examination commercial truck
drivers also have to have
examinations police officers have to
have health examinations and have to do
physical fitness tests so there are
those types of provisions that you want
to be
aware of as to whether or not you want
to include those in in such a definition
the other question had to do with
informed consent
and
in that area i ended up in the american
medical association's ethics
treatises
and
read a fair amount about informed
consent in new hampshire law also has
requirements regarding informed consent
and informed consent is the process
where
communication between a patient and a
doctor result in the patient
understanding
a treatment understanding the possible
positive and negative outcomes
in in conjunction with the
this condition that the patient has
they understand what the specific
medical intervention is and what will
occur during that procedure that is
necessary
they understand
any of the options for payment
and for
after care requirements
and that this informed consent
conversation occurs so that the doctor
is comfortable that the patient
understands all of these provisions and
the patient is then able to make an
informed decision
based on the information the patient has
received and all of that needs to be
documented in
the patient's medical records
the one exception to all of this is that
in the case of an emergency if the
patient isn't available and no other
individual who has the ability to make
decisions for the patient is available
then the physicians can initiate
treatment without informed consent and
essentially informed consent needs to be
given after the fact by a full
explanation of what the treatment was
and why the decision was made
as it was and what other opportunities
or treatments are available from there
i believe those respond to the specific
questions that came out in the
invitation so i'm more than happy to
answer any of the questions that i can
and as i said i'll remain during the
hearing so in case there's something
that comes up that you'd like to ask me
afterwards thank you thank you very much
is there any questions from the
committee representative leon um thank
you mr chair uh thank you for being here
thank you i'm not good at these
microphones thank you for being here and
answering these questions uh when you're
speaking to the emergency and when a
patient can't consent um we actually
work through the advanced directive
change in the law last year
um
is are the doctors able to override a
patient if they are saying that they do
not want the treatment
and where is that line
so that's a really difficult question to
answer
it it really is fact based on what the
situation is
and if the patient says no and the
patient is mentally able to make that
decision then the doctors don't override
those decisions because a patient can
choose to not accept treatment if a
patient wants to do so the the challenge
becomes whether or not the patient's
cognitive functions are impaired during
that time period either because they're
ill or because they're injured or for
some other reason such as a substance
use
challenge and in that in those cases
then
they're depending on what the documents
are there's usually a secondary person
who can make decisions for a patient who
is not able to make decisions on their
own and that person will be contacted
thank you you're welcome
goalie
thank you mr chair um
what happens if
a law is put in place
that conflicts with federal law
that's an excellent question if it's a
duly enacted federal law and it applies
to all of the states then the state of
new hampshire
is most likely required to follow that
law unless there's a challenge to that
law and so as a result part of what
you're seeing right now with respect to
different rules such as the osha rule
requiring
individuals
requiring employers of more than a
hundred employees to have vaccinations
or have a testing protocol the state
attorneys general in different states
are challenging that law and they're in
that rule and the reason for that is
because when those rules go into place
as long as they're duly enacted
correctly they are valid laws whether or
not the
content of the law is constitutional or
not is a different question as to
whether or not it's a duly enacted law
and if it's a duly enacted law then
we're required to follow that federal
law if it applies to us
we have a follow-up to that jeff for a
second i just want to make sure we're
talking about basically the supremacy
clause right in the constitution that
says that federal law
trumps state law yes and and i think the
to one of representative goli's points
is we're dealing with not necessarily a
federal law that was gone through the
legislative process but we're dealing
with an executive order out of a single
branch of government as compared to a
state law that's gone through the
legislative process and two branches of
government in theory
and does the supremacy clause apply to
executive orders so that's an excellent
question what i was speaking about
specifically was the rule which is
different than the executive order that
is going through the process
under the federal government's system
for
enacting rules with respect to the
executive order it's the same type of
position
if the executive order is duly enacted
then we as a state and it applies to us
if we as a state are required to follow
it unless we challenge it that is the
point of our third branch of government
and that's why we raise those challenges
in court
you have a follow-up jeff
so again i think we've seen the attorney
general's office
has
signed on but i'm not i can't remember
whether that relative to the executive
order or to the osha rule and
challenging the osh rule i don't recall
so we have currently a letter
outstanding that we issued with respect
to the osha rule with i think 24 other
attorneys general raising concerns about
that that rule has not come out of
the committee yet it hasn't been
put in in place so as a result
that doesn't have a court action against
it the court action that we joined last
week is with respect to the executive
order and the requirement that federal
contractors
have to
require
their employees and additional employees
who have contact with them it's quite a
broad group of people that are falling
under that
provision in the executive order so we
are challenging that
and we are challenged in one of the
reasons we are challenging that at this
point is it is now in
it is now
being implicated against state agencies
so the
business in economic affairs has
received a notice vital statistics has
received a notice regarding it and so we
now have a basis for being able to
challenge that for our state agencies
one follow-up question so
if the legislature enacted a law does
that make the
ag's office case stronger weaker if we
enacted a law that had to deal with
mandates and federal mandates that have
to be duly acted laws versus rules or
regulations
um
or i should say rules or exempt or
executive orders does that help the
attorney general's office
so these lawsuits are are going to be in
federal court and the federal court
looks at state law and certainly would
look at a duly enacted state law as the
intent of the state of new hampshire but
that state law wouldn't necessarily
override
a federal
executive order or a even
specifically a federal law that would be
something that the court would take into
consideration as an interest that the
state is showing as an official position
but it doesn't mean that it would
overrule it even with the executive
order if the executive order was duly
enacted
thank you
i have one more if nobody else says
anything so i'm going to go back to the
informed consent conversation is the
assumption in an informed consent
conversation that the
the consent is given freely and
voluntarily without coercion or threat
yes
thank you
thank you and i have
one other question from the legislation
from senate bill 74 last year
there is language there that says that
recognizing this right which is the
right to make your health care decisions
and to refuse health care treatments the
refusal of health care treatments is not
sufficient to demonstrate that a person
lacks capacity to make health care
decisions
yes no concerns there no no concerns at
all i mean that is the state of new
hampshire state law and i would argue
that's the state of federal law people
can choose not to accept treatment okay
and um that same bill also said that if
somebody if somebody's refusal then
leads to a declaration of incompetence
um that it protects the fact that
they've refused this in the start of the
cascade in order to to have a higher
burden um actually if there's any other
questions let me get that exact language
i apologize
i'll ask one more while she's looking up
her language so i'm gonna go
back to hp 220 and then in all of open
fairness we've had conversations around
hp 220 before yeah as i was the prime
sponsor of that bill
um
relative to hb 220 is it your
interpretation of that law that only
applies to the covid
vaccine or does it apply to all
vaccinations and immunizations so it's
the attorney general's interpretation of
that law that it only applies to covet
vaccines
thank you
i think that answered my question enough
thank you thank you
we'll sit in thank you for the comments
next up is dhhs i think beth daley is
here
[Music]
good morning i'm beth daly the bureau
chief for infectious disease control at
the new hampshire department of health
and human services
i'm joined today hi good morning melissa
st there i'm the chief legal officer for
the department of health and human
services
and i understand that there were some
questions for for dhhs to answer related
to the definition of medical
intervention
currently the department does not have a
definition for medical intervention that
that term does not exist in our say 141c
which is our communicable disease
statute and so we don't have that term
in
our statute nor in our rules
um certainly there are interventions i
guess you could say that um that are
that the department conducts uh things
under 141c including
isolation and quarantine orders
required treatment for those who are at
risk to spread a communicable disease
and other things that i'm sure beth
could speak to a little bit more
certainly we're here to answer any
questions and are happy to um providing
information that the committee would
like
great yeah and i'll just add a little
bit more detail about 141c and what the
department where we have shells so there
is a requirement for
certain vaccinations for a child in
child care and school entry um those are
under 141 c
a
there are two permitted
exemptions
whereby parents can not have their child
vaccinated and they can still choose to
go to school or still attend school or
child care and those are for
medical reasons if someone can't
medically be vaccinated or for religious
beliefs and then there's a notarized
notarized form that they can fill out
um for that purpose and present to the
school so that this the child can be
allowed
um
in terms of those are that's really the
only shell i think for medical
intervention in this section
um on that applies routinely we do have
the authority to issue
orders for treatment which is quite
uncommon for us to do
the disease that we do the most
uh have done that most frequently for is
tuberculosis so in our state
if someone is diagnosed with
tuberculosis which can be a deadly
condition and globally is a leading
cause of death
we do compel them to receive antibiotic
treatment so that they're not out in the
community potentially infecting other
individuals obviously the vast majority
of people want to take this treatment um
freely and usually when issued presented
with an order
they do comply with the the treatment
and we've not had someone um there is a
due process outlined for them in the
statute
and we've not had people
uh take that course of action to to
object to the order and it's usually
just a matter of them understanding the
importance of the treatment
so that's it i think in terms of shells
i did just to piggyback onto what ann
edwards said had said about
requirements for medical intervention
for employment
there i just wanted to mention it's not
pertain it's not from dhhs or it's not a
state requirement but there are some
um
jobs that require vaccinations as well
and one particular one i just wanted to
highlight for you was rabies vaccine so
if you work in a veterinary office or if
you work in a laboratory that processes
rabies specimens because it's a 100
percent uh fatal disease there's only
one person that we know of that survived
that disease they do require rabies
vaccine as well so again that's another
thing you might want to consider as you
look at the scope of your
work here
that's it
questions for dhhs
um thank you mr chair and thank you both
for being here today uh when you speak
to the orders that can be issued by dhhs
do those need to be individual orders or
could those be blanket orders
no there are individual orders
pertaining to a specific individual
we've issued them for isolation and
quarantine
and then the treatment ones that i
mentioned as well and they pertain to a
specific
individual
and we have a reason for a justification
for that order do you want to try yeah
no that's that's exactly right and so
when an individual is issued an order um
they obviously you know have the
opportunity to comply with the order or
there's also the due process um that
beth mentioned earlier that they can
appeal that um and go in and so it has
to apply to the individual so that they
have their they can go through that due
process um
rights type of um hearing if they if
they so choose
can you speak into the microphone i'm
just going to comment online that they
can't hear you when you're speaking
happy to do so
thank you um i guess the other question
is you say that the rabies vaccine is
mandated for employment because of the
100 fatality rate it's my understanding
that while flu vaccines are required for
some employment there are there are
accommodations for those
that's correct right
so there are a number of other vaccines
that might be required for certain types
of employment they might require
hepatitis b vaccine influenza those are
some of the most common ones if you work
in health care or in a laboratory
it really depends there's no state law
that is required one time
well i think i'll take that question
just in terms of explaining the
requirements for schools so there are a
number of uh
vaccines that require multiple doses in
a series
many times the children get all of the
doses they need for example you
mentioned hepatitis b which is a three
dose series
and
the diphtheria tetanus and acellular
pertussis vaccine has four or five doses
so they actually are getting multiple
doses
most of those vaccines though are not
annual vaccines which i think is what
your point is what about flu we don't
require flu for a child care and school
entry um norocovid yet
um most of the times where you're
proving that you've met the vaccine
requirements is at the kindergarten
entry and then again there are some
vaccines that you do need again
such as the tdap vaccine tetanus
diphtheria and acellular pertussis
because whooping cough
has been shown that your immunity wanes
over time and so you do need additional
doses of that throughout your lifetime
potentially just to get your tetanus
vaccine every 10 years right so you do
need additional vaccines in order to
attend seventh grade is usually where
that's about happening again and then
the schools keep track of the kids
vaccination status and if they're
missing any for example at that seventh
grade entry point they're probably
providing it or as they go to middle
school providing that so i think your
your point is correct that for school
and child care entry currently
um the burden of
to be able to enter is only happening
once or two times throughout the child's
course of school attendance because
we're not requiring
annual vaccines there's not an annual
vaccine requirement at this point
does that answer that help or answer
your question
so i have a couple for you um so you
talked about um tb right so that was on
how many times has the commissioner used
its authority to
require
a citizen against their wills i guess is
the real question if someone volunteers
for it it's not an issue even if it is a
shell
but when someone chose not to volunteer
to have their the proper treatment for
tb that the commissioner forced that how
many has that ever occurred and if so
how many times
um we have ordered
isolation and treatment for people with
tuberculosis it's very rare but i
actually have to go back and look um how
often this happens
i think we've written an order one time
this year for tuberculosis
maybe a few you know once a year or so
that happens out of the 20 or so
tuberculosis cases that we get each year
in new hampshire
oftentimes what happens is the
individual doesn't understand the
importance of the um
treatment and when you know we're trying
to explain to them why it's so important
for them to treat it and then when you
present them within order they're like
oh you you know you were serious that
this is really important and i will do
it again no one has come no one has
entered through that due process of
actually ultimately refusing to be
treated for example
thank you um relative to the uh you
mentioned rabies in certain
circumstances for a process so i guess i
guess my question is again going about
mandates and conversations under
i recall under federal law there was
there was originally uh
a thing about business mandates or
mandates in general especially in the
healthcare field
having to be correlated as a direct
threat to the job function
and then the language they use is a
direct threat um does that apply to any
of the mandates that we're currently
looking at or is it just a broad mandate
that has no correlation to job function
but only correlation to whether or not
we want to get the vaccine or not do you
want to speak to this i don't know if
you looked into the direct threat
language
yeah
um i don't know that i'm that familiar i
know that has been incorporated in and
was in part of the discussions last year
around it um i think part of that direct
threat language has to do with um
for example in a healthcare setting
there's
potential harm that would come to the
patients that they're serving which is
the justification for
um requiring vaccination those settings
but i don't think i can speak more to
the federal law around that or wording
okay
um and going back you had said there
were limited places in the
law or rules that you apply a shell but
one of the ones you didn't talk about is
the whole reason i filed hp 220 which
was the vaccine requirements around
foster families and rather than create
an exemption kind of situation where if
you had a child who was i mean who
compromised you would require that child
to go to a vaccinated family you created
the broad
rule
that says if you want to be a foster
parent the entire family including all
the children in that family must be
vaccinated isn't that true
um that is not under my purview that was
under another agency within dhhs do you
want to can you speak to that
[Music]
thank you for the question so uh our uh
dcyf program is responsible for the
for the administration of that rule and
so
they're not here unfortunately today to
speak to that specific foster parent
rule uh from what i understand
they felt it was important to
ensure that foster parents and the
children within those households that
are caring for for foster children
receive the covet vaccine
and in that it is within their ability
to to do so i'm sorry they were not
required to get the code vaccine they're
required to get influenza and other
vaccines but not the coveted vaccine
sorry i misspoke there so uh i i i can
certainly get more information and more
more
i can ask for dcyf to
give you more information on the
requirements for foster parents if
that's what you would like
i'm familiar with it i just want to make
sure we understand that there is at
least one other place and i don't know
because you know where else it might be
but i know at least one other place
where it's a shall
it's in your rules and it just it's one
of the things this committee needs you
know is the whole reason i filed 220 was
i sat on jail car when that rule came
through and opposed it then on religious
grounds because there were no exemptions
really allowed within the rule um but
it's just a broad-based shell for every
foster family must get vaccinated and
and i don't know where else and i was
hoping you were coming with answers
where in your rules and laws you had
shells like that that i know about but i
obviously don't know all of your rules
and i was hoping you were coming
prepared to answer it that you've read
the materials as part of the
registration process so that's how most
organizations are doing that that's how
our state-run vaccination clinics
operated as well and you know many of
the pharmacies and healthcare
organizations that have registration
portals for vaccination appointments
we'll
ask you to look at these documents as
part of the registration before you go
ahead and schedule
great there's a follow-up question that
because of your answer so
relative to that
one we just heard from the attorney
general's office that consent needs to
be giving freely and without threat how
do you get around the the people who are
being don't want to take the vaccine but
or have their livelihoods being
threatened and being forced to take in
the vaccine they have to make the
decision between do i keep a house over
my head and food on my table where do i
get the shot how is how do you define
that how do you make sure that the
person's giving a free and informed
consent that's that's voluntary and not
coerced
so i think that's part of the issues
that you all are addressing here i don't
have an answer to that question for you
so i guess my question is around the
ethics of it so again my question is
around is is that if is it ethically
correct
for the state
or or a doctor to give a shot that's
being coerced by an employer
under the threat of
keeping a house over my head and food on
my table for my children is is that
ethically correct
is that something we should be looking
into is that something that
you know just as a straight ethics issue
we that should be addressed in the in
the uh within your agency
um
yeah i don't have an answer for you to
that question i mean there's
laws and rules and regulations that come
forward that require
certain things to happen and that you
have to interpret those within the
context of other
laws and rules and regulations that
exist
but i'm not the one administering the
vaccine right
[Music]
i'm sorry doesn't a vaccine program fall
within your agency that the state's
running um sorry i am not administering
the vaccine so the you know i personally
am not a vaccine administer i'm not a
health care provider i'm an
epidemiologist and public health
official and we make our role at the
health department is to make the
vaccines available to the public
who want to get vaccinated why someone
is choosing to get vaccinated is up to
that individual right whatever
constraints they have upon them as a
person
informs their decision making but i'm
not engaged in that process of it
i just make the vaccine available to
them if they want it
thank you and i and i will say that
medical providers
are overseen by the office of
professional licensure the board of
medicine the board of nursing those who
are responsible for the administration
of the vaccination
they have their own
laws and regulations that they must
follow that's not under the purview of
the department of health and human
services that's under the
office of professional licensure but
certainly
we would expect
it and
hope that all individuals are ethically
receiving a vaccination
but it would be if there are complaints
or anything like that related to that
type of coercion you're speaking of that
would go to the office of professional
licensure for their for their review
i guess the reason i was asking because
you were saying you were running
licensing clinics dhhs is running
licensing clinics i'm assuming you're
responsible for everything that occurs
within that clinic if you're running it
and so i'm i'm just concerned that our
as a state we're not taking on a
liability because we're not asking the
right questions about whether it's
freely given consent or is it is it
forced or coerced consent by an employer
to keep your job
uh thank you so at the vaccination
clinics um the individuals no one is
being forced to take a vaccine every
everyone who comes to those has
presented saying that they want to
receive the vaccine and they're there
freely on their own you know own accord
we're not requiring anyone to get
vaccinated holding people down to
vaccinate them
it's they're there they presented to get
the vaccine because
they have made the choice to get
vaccinated for whatever reason
i think what my point is about whether
that consent is freely given or whether
it's coerced or threatened and whether
or not a doctor has an ethical ethical
obligation to understand whether that's
a force or free consent or is it because
you're being threatened with your
livelihood
that's all
right roberto goldie
thank you mr chair and this
i guess would be addressed to your
concern to you as we are already doing a
number of these with flu vaccines with
businesses requiring other vaccinations
or other
immunizations for employment
is that where we're going with this or
is it just specifically with the kovajic
well again i think right now we're
speaking
we're talking about vaccinations in
general and we're just seeing it we're
in unprecedented times i think where
we're seeing mandates that are causing
mass exodus to our workforce right we
had uh i think i read something like 26
fire departments were shut down in new
york city because the firemen who
refused to get
vaccinations and that now creates a
different public safety issue um that's
going on so i guess the concern is
generally around um we've never seen
these kind of mandates before right in
an unprecedented fashion where people
are being threatened with their jobs
and you know other other reasons why
if someone goes into the nursing
industry prior to this they knew they
had choices to make um and we know that
there's a federal decision about that
mandates and direct threats and nurses
could choose to take
what doctors could choose to go into
parts of medicare medical um
treatment that
wouldn't have compromise compromised
people so they don't have to worry about
i don't want to get the vaccine i'm not
going to be around immune compromised
people like cancer wards right so i'll
go work in podiatry instead right where
i'm not where it's not such a big issue
right so they had those choices now
they're not even being given those
choices and i think the question is
around that is that people are being
their livelihoods are being threatened
and does that impact informed consent
right and the ability to give free
and voluntarily voluntary informed
consent or not is with their livelihoods
being threatened like that now because
now you can't even go be a podiatrist
without having the vaccine so now you're
getting no choice
so i think that's part of where we're
having this conversation is where where
does that go how does that work um how
does that intervention work uh that
medical intervention and immunization
work in our society uh and is is
informed consent now thrown out the
window
and if i just may respond briefly that
and that's that's where i'm going is
there's already requirements for other
vaccines
for these medical fields
in place and that's all i wanted to make
was that comment thank you
thank you
thank you you've spoken to the side the
consent part of informed consent the
discussion of
people having to click through and say
that they've read the information packet
and the fact that they don't ask a
question when the person administering
the vaccine says do you have any
questions it that doesn't seem
like that's informed to me when we're on
our computers we click through and say
yes we accept the terms i'd like to
understand how the department views
an informed patient and what kind of
information should be available and
ethically
should make sure that people are truly
informed about
so the process that we are using is
pretty standard process of providing the
information to the individual who is
saying that they have read it and agreed
to it so i think the responsibility is
on them
for people who don't have internet
access or whatnot they have those
documents are provided to them
in fact they're often provided anyhow
routinely to people when they're at
getting their vaccination they have that
information presented to them in there
so if they have any questions about it
there's ample opportunity to
to ask questions if you have any
concerns about getting the vaccine
obviously the people who are signing up
to get vaccinated are people who have
already you know made the choice that
they don't have questions or concerns
they've had those answered and they want
to get vaccinated
i'm just trying to wrap my head around
how these novel vaccines are treated
differently than other
novel
treatments other biologics other
procedures and why there's more
information and more discussion of that
information needed for other
interventions because we're looking not
just at vaccines we're looking at
medical interventions more broadly
why is there a different standard of
consent of
information
um i personally am not sure where there
is a different standard in that
as i said the process that we use is
like processes used for other
vaccinations when you sign up to get
vaccinated
that's it's all based on this a similar
process that happens for influenza
vaccine or other vaccines that you get
it's a standard process okay so your
knowledge is simply limited to those
vaccinations and not to broader medical
practice
for me personally i can't speak to
broader medical practice i'm not a
healthcare provider
thank you
actually and do you have any insight to
that
i was just going to say that for
typically for novel uh vaccinations
those that you're under eua the federal
government requires additional
information to be provided to
individuals who are receiving a
vaccination that may not have received
full
authority to
under the fda so so there are there may
be additional information that's
required but the process wouldn't
necessarily change it would just ensure
that
that whatever additional information is
necessary and the eua very very well
could require additional process and in
that situation they'd be
you know medical practitioners would be
required to follow that
okay i'm just trying to understand how
somebody with terminal cancer can be
denied a therapy because they didn't go
through all the process for information
yet we don't have that standard here so
that's something that's probably better
to ask of somebody else i'm just trying
to understand this thank you
any further questions for
miss daley
thank you for coming i appreciate it
thank you
next up is erica
representative leons
next up is chris bond with the
department of education
good morning chris bond
new hampshire department of education
so i think i
i um
mostly i'm here to take questions but i
can speak briefly to the questions that
the committee posed
in terms of shallow shall not for
medical interventions such as masks and
vaccines i'm not aware of any shell or
shell knots as to masks or vaccines
vaccines of course are addressed broadly
in rsa 141c which health and human
services spoke to
masks
it's the department's interpretation
that the
uh
state board in delegating authority to
local school boards to
uh have health and safety policies have
effectively delegated the mask uh issue
to to local to localities and there's no
reference in the statutes that i'm aware
of to masks but um there are a few areas
where there are and again uh to echo
what um others have said already there's
no definition of um medical intervention
in any of the um
rsas relating to the department of
education that i'm aware of there are a
few instances where there's shells and
shell shells and maize
or what might be thought of as medical
intervention so i can just lay a few of
those out
for example
rsa 240-a
says that school nurses shall be
permitted to administer oxygen to a
pupil in a medical emergency without
parental permission
um
rsa 242
200 colon 42 uh provides that pupils can
possess and self may possess and
self-administer epipens or epinephrine
auto injector pens
um
similarly rsa 244 a
requires that schools designate certain
personnel to have anaphylaxis training
including the administration of an
epipen in an emergency basis
rsa 246
provides that pupils may possess and
self-administer asthma inhalers
but there has to be my understanding is
there at the ba
plan on file with the school
approved by the parents for that
rsa 254
says that school boards may authorize
their school nurse to maintain a supply
of bronchodilators spacers or nebulizers
for use in an emergency situation
and rsa 255
provides that a parent may
put written permission on file with the
school for someone other than a nurse to
administer a nebulizer or bronchodilator
or spacer in an emergency situation
and rsa
excuse me rsa 200 colon 40 requires
schools to develop written policies for
immediate and adequate emergency care so
to the extent that any of those items
might be considered medical
interventions i wanted to bring those
to the committee's attention
and then let me see if i had
yeah so i think that was all the
examples that uh that i was able to find
of something that i thought might be
responsive but i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you very much thank you for
getting prepared with the with the
places anybody on the committee have a
question for
chris
department of education
i guess i just want to be clear so the
department of education's policy
regarding masking
is that it's up to local school boards
to make a determination based on their
public health policies
yeah that's correct so um
uh the
let me see i just think i might be able
to find a reference in our
administrative rules that will be
helpful
um
so
under rsa 21n the state board of
education is empowered to create
administrative rules for the operation
of public schools and in doing that
they've enacted the
the
ed 300 rules which include
ed
303.01 which says that each school board
shall provide that all school building
and other learning environments be
maintained in a manner consistent with
standards of health and safety
ed 306.04
which says that in accordance with ed
30301 or referenced above the local
school board shall adopt and implement
written policies and procedures relative
to promoting school safety wellness and
meeting the physical health needs of
students
306.04 d
states that
the policy relative promoting school
safety shall require school
administrators to implement procedures
which relate to safe practices so the
department has interpreted those
delegations by the state board to mean
that the decision on whether to have a
mask policy is uh properly within the
purview of the local school board
thank you and follow up to that
other than what's in rsa 141c regarding
communicable diseases and school
attendance there's no rules
or laws that you're familiar with other
than that that chapter of law relative
to vaccination requirements for school
attendance
that's correct my understanding is that
the vaccination requirements are
addressed in 141 c20a with the um the
opt out
policies that are that are part of that
statute but i don't know of any other
area where that's addressed thank you
representative
um thank you this might be
a bit too much of a clarifying question
would it be
would it be possible for a local school
board to require vaccinations beyond the
public health requirements
no the department has taken the position
that that rsa 141c leaves that authority
in the legislature except to the extent
that it's been delegated to the
commissioner of health and human
services where there is a provision to
add and the department has taken the
step of issuing a technical advisory to
schools i believe it was dated june 7th
where we specifically told schools
schools may not add to the
list of required vaccinations because
that process for deciding what is a
required vaccination is governed by 141c
exclusively
so and the department takes the position
that that applies to non-public schools
as well as public schools because
non-public schools
that are approved by the department of
education for
compulsory attendance law purposes have
to comply with uh the ed 400 rules which
incorporate 141c
thank you you're welcome
awesome
barbara
representative
okay i guess she's all set
um
[Music]
i think she's looking something up um
i guess i'll ask a generic question here
and that's relative to
um we've seen
at the um
lately what's going on with school
boards
right and and and and various activities
around that are there any laws or
anything that you can think of that the
legislature should look at that deal
with some of these things like masking
um that that's being
um rallied about at school boards is
there any place that we should be
considering a law to ease these kind of
tensions so they don't occur
do you have any kind of input in that
area
um i mean that is a broad question and
to the extent that it it touches on
policy i know the commissioner
thinks it's important that parent input
be part of decisions on masking
so i mean i think it's the department's
understanding that those decisions are
right now
based on the current structure placed
with the localities um so
i mean
in terms of resolving the tensions i
suppose it resolves the tension in one
way if the legislature were to decide
well we're going to make a masking
policy protocol or put or put guardrails
on those i suppose that limits the
tension and to the extent that that
takes that
policy decision out of the hands of
local officials where a lot of those
clashes are happening but i don't know
if that might just move the tension to a
different level um but that that again
that's not i don't know that that's a
question that i'm
um
qualified to weigh in on i would just
say that the commissioner feels very
strongly that uh parents should have a a
role in a say in whether there's masking
policies that apply to their children
and how those are applied
thank you
anybody else
thank you i will ask one more i
apologize i used to be a device and
diagnostic analyst
this is my wheelhouse um does the
department have any policies on the
diagnostics and how
students test to return or is that all
simply left to the department of public
health
um we have not gotten
very involved in in that we have
generally stayed away from testing as
deferring to public health um with the
exception of we have been very clear to
schools that any testing that
is done should have
parental consent for it
we've also been very clear to schools
that
under their
obligations to comply with ferpa which
is a federal student privacy law
any medical information they collect
from students is a educational record
under that statute and they need to be
very careful that they're maintaining
those records
with the appropriate level of privacy
but other than that other than the
privacy issue and parental consent we
have not had any uh input that i'm aware
of into the how the testing regimes are
working out thank you
thank you anything else for the
department of education
not saying anything thank you chris for
coming thank you very much thank you
who's up next erica
up next is court uh cordell johnston
from the new hampshire municipal
association
let me get myself settled here
um
good morning i'm cordell johnston
representing the new hampshire municipal
association
uh and i'm here because i was invited
and i don't really have a whole lot to
add
um i'm happy to answer questions
at the at the municipal level and i
should say
i don't have a definition of medical
intervention um
but at the municipal level
the only
examples that i can think of
that i think
that i would
uh identify as medical interventions
would be in some kind of emergency
context
a couple of people have mentioned um
involuntary admissions
which would be
which the police department might be
involved in
uh chairman lang rep
mentioned
narcan
administered in a in an overdose
situation and that that would be
typically
emts or perhaps the police department
but again emergency responders
and i can imagine
there
probably are
other emergency situations where
uh someone might be administering
um some kind of sedative or pain
reliever for you know extreme
if an accident victim is in
is in extreme pain
but those are
those are the things i can think of and
i don't really know much about those i
know that representatives of the police
chiefs association and the fire chiefs
association have been invited so they
probably can
speak better than i can
the the only other thing
that i can think of that
might be considered
medical intervention would be drug
testing
which um
private employers
i believe
uh i'm not an expert on this but i
believe that private employers
are
more or less unrestricted in their
ability to require drug testing for
their employees
governmental entities are subject to a
lot more restriction because
if you're actually testing someone for
drugs and if that's being done by a
local government or a state government
that i think is considered to be a
search or seizure
and it's subject to the
unreasonable search or seizure provision
of the fourth amendment
and that's why
i believe municipalities cannot
routinely
test uh
require their employees to undergo a
drug test
there is an exception for
cdl drivers and and i think maybe a few
other limited exceptions and as i
understand it the courts have indicated
that because of you know there's a
there's a balancing test and if you're
testing someone who's driving a a
highway truck for the town
um the safety importance outweighs the
um
uh
outweighs the unreasonable search or
seizure
concern
um but that's the that's the only other
instance that i can think of and as i
say other than that
you're talking about emergency
situations involving emergency
responders
as far as
municipalities as employers
um you know there's
uh you know obviously uh
employers requiring
uh their employees to be vaccinated
right now is a big issue
and i think um
i would view municipal employers
in the same
light as
private employers
as far as i know there are no municipal
employers that have
that have required
uh vaccines for any of their employees
um
[Music]
and i don't know and i wouldn't
necessarily know if there were but as
far as i know they're not requiring that
and that's as i say that's about all i
have to say i'd be happy to try to
answer questions
any questions from the committee
i'll ask a couple
um
so um
so this is also about what we could
possibly do where there's where this
causing tension between municipalities
and the state and how to manage that a
little bit better relative to these
mandates that are going around is there
anywhere you can speak of for your
members that you think there should be
some clarification or some cleanup
in any statute that is relative to this
medical intervention or immunizations
that would help municipalities
i don't think so i mean as i said it
it's
uh municipalities i mean whether it's
covert or something else as far as i
know
uh municipalities have not uh
traditionally
required immunizations or
or
wanted to
um i i and i think on the assumption
that
you know immunizations generally
for the worst uh diseases generally
occur when you're
four or five six years old
um and so
uh
when you're at the level of a
municipality hiring someone as an
employee
it really it really is not an issue and
certainly
going beyond the employee context and
and uh trying to require anyone else to
be immunized i think would be uh
pretty far out of bounds
so i
our our members are not asking for any
kind of legislation or clarification as
far as i know
thank you and regarding the drug testing
you were talking about in certain
circumstances that's usually relative to
the federal federal motor carrier law uh
requirements so trucks over a certain
size that kind of thing and that's why
they're required because they have to
have a cdl license as compared to just a
regular driver's license that's my
understanding yeah thank you
um thank you i just would like to ask a
clarifying question it sounds that
you would not support any municipality
that tried to put on their own vaccine
requirement or other requirements beyond
that of public health
so
we would not uh sorry i didn't quite
we did see with masks which are a
removable intervention so that's that we
saw that some towns that put those into
place um you don't see any expectation
that any towns or cities would try and
create their own vaccine requirement for
citizens
or anybody else in that in their within
the bounds
i i
i mean
you know i i hate to i hate to say i i
can't imagine something because i can
imagine almost anything uh but i
as if you're talking about
as a municipality requiring citizens to
be vaccinated
i i
almost can't imagine that i i really
don't think you know imposing you know
the city of concord imposing a
requirement that everyone in concord be
immunized um
no i i don't
i don't think so
thank you we're just trying to beat
around these edges and make sure that we
have clean edges thank you very much so
again i think i'm trying i don't
remember the rsa but there's an rsa
relative to they have a general welfare
clause to what cities can pass and do
and i and we had a bill last year to
deal with that to try to clean that up
just i think on this for this reason so
i guess the question is
is it possible under that rsa which i
can't remember the number of it but i'm
sure you know it
that uses that general welfare clause of
the citizens would it be possible for
them under current state law to create a
broad
community vaccine requirement
uh and
given hp 220 as well um
just to be clear if
for a town that would be rsa 147 one
or a city it would be rsa 4717
paragraph something
so would it be possible under
those statutes for a city or town to
institute a an immunization requirement
for citizens
maybe
um
i mean
the the language is pretty broad
um
so
it's
it
it's hard to say
um
yeah all i can say is maybe it depends
on how you interpret it again
whether any
the idea that any municipality would
actually try to do that
um i think that's
that's very hard to imagine
so so the specific sentence just so
everyone's clear is under one uh for
cities anyways 47 17
and it's section 15 and there's a
sentence in there it says they may make
any other bylaws or regulations which
they seem
to be for the well-being of the city and
i guess that's my concern is that
sentences that sentence give broad
latitude um or would that be a conflict
do you think with hp 220 that says
government can't mandate immunizations
um
well
hb 220 as i read it doesn't doesn't say
you can't mandate immunizations it says
you can't require them as a condition to
receiving a public benefit or whatever
um
but
uh
as i said
you know someone the language is pretty
vague so someone could read that and say
yeah that allows us to do whatever we
want
um and therefore we're going to mandate
immunizations for everybody
um
i don't i really don't think anyone's
gonna do that
and and i don't think that legislative i
suppose
if
if a city or town tried to do that that
might be the time when you would say we
need legislation to clarify that you
can't do that
um
and i mean if and i haven't looked at
all these bills
they're not all available yet but maybe
there's one in there that says that no
municipality can require
that its citizens be
immunized
and that certainly would would because
that's more specific that would
preempt any
uh effort to try to do that either under
forty seven seventeen or under one forty
seven one
thank you
okay anything else for goodell
cordell thank you very much for coming
appreciate it thank you
next up erica next up is barrett
christina from the new hampshire school
board association
good morning chairman lag members of the
committee bearer christina from the new
hampshire school boards association um i
appreciate uh representative lyon you
calling on the department before you
called on me because my testimony is uh
essentially similar similar to what
attorney bond from the department of
education testified to a few minutes ago
um i i brought with me copies of the
same statutes in the the rsa200 series
that attorney bond referenced school
health services
school physician physical examination of
pupils uh so on and so forth medical
examination of school personnel school
bus operators as you uh reference to
representative lang
um the the pertinent statute rsa 141 uh
c20 i believe it is uh to the specific
questions that were um uh uh asked uh to
ask to prepare for our testimony about
support of showers shown off for medical
intervention such as masks vaccines and
other procedures
nhsba
has advised our members since the
pandemic to follow the advice
and recommendations both from governor
sununu and commissioner edward blue that
mask requirements or mass mandates would
be a local decision one of the bedrock
principles nhsba advocates for is local
decision making of local educational
matters so we did not tell our members
to implement mass mandates we did not
tell our members not to implement mass
mandates we said listen to your parents
listen to the health experts and make a
decision on what's best for your local
community
relative to the definition of medical
intervention i think that's been i think
that's been covered significantly from
some of the other people that have
testified i don't have a definition of
that um what i can tell you though is
that through the series of statutes in
the rsa 200 series
as well as department of education rule
i believe it's 311 and 312 which talk
about some school health services
the only time there isn't any
necessarily per se informed consent
would be in a first aid situation with a
student you know kid falls off the the
jungle gym or trips and falls and they
have to you know bandage up his knee or
whatever it might be
but all the other aspects
about
nebulizers and uh insulin and things of
that nature they are or medication
during the school day they all require
some level of parental consent a note
from the doctor uh parents signing off
on it parents requesting that the the
inhaler the the insulin be provided at
school or stored at school
um i know from the doctor saying how
often you know johnny or susie needs
this medicine or needs the insulin or
signs to look out for so
um within the school context um
there's no there's no there's no
uninformed consent short of an emergency
situation where a student um requires
you know essential first aid uh one
point that i do want to uh just clarify
i believe um representative lang you
asked about rules relative to
um immunizations are under rsa 141 c20c
there is a department of education rule
it's ed311 um and
all the only thing that this rule does
is basically restate the statute a
parent or legal guardian shall have a
child immunized against certain diseases
as determined in in rules hep i presume
that's health and human services um
immunization requirements adopted by
commissioner of department of health and
human services the child shall be exempt
from immunization in accordance with rsa
141 c20c that's the religious exemption
and the um uh if the if the vaccine
would cause a medical harm to the to the
individual
and you get a note from a doctor from
that a child is exempt from
immunizations a child who is exempt from
immunizations in accordance with
paragraph b shall not attend school
during an outbreak of a communicable
disease if a child is not immunized does
not have a religious or medical
exemption or is unable to provide
evidence of acceptable immunization for
condition of enrollment he or she shall
not be admitted to school
that restates what the statute basically
states anyway but i just wanted to bring
you uh to your attention that there is a
rule that speaks uh department of
education rule that does speak to the
immunization requirements the rule
following that
311.02 medication during the school day
again very prescriptive requires
parental consent bringing a note from
the doctor things of that nature so um i
don't think i have anything new to add
um but i'm happy to answer any questions
that the committee may have
okay anybody from the committee
i'm gonna have one
of course um so i because you brought up
the the whole uh area around medical
exemptions for schools
um given that the uh attorney the the um
what is the surgeon general has has said
that they want to look at religious
exemptions again and whether or not
they're being abused
um
the question i have is is it is it a
proper role for schools to decide how
religious an individual person is
whether or not they're entitled to an
exemption is that something we should
tighten up or clean up or is that just
so broad that it leaves you exposed yeah
thank you thank you for the question
representative i did see you have a bill
and i saw some of the language um about
broadening i believe your bill says
religious exemption medical notary
conscience objector i believe that was
the phrase that's being used
we don't have a position we mean nhsba
doesn't have a position on vaccines just
in and of themselves especially as it
relates to kovid
you know we have not been asked whether
or not we can man we meaning school
districts can mandate employers or
students to be vaccined to either attend
school or to continue employment we just
haven't gotten that question
so i i don't want to give a firm answer
to your question just yet representative
i've seen the bill
i don't know if any sba will be
testifying on it when we get into the
legislative session but we will
certainly be tracking it um and i just i
would want to do more research on
perhaps what other states have um on
their laws relative to immunizations and
and opt-outs and parental consent and
things of that nature before i offer a
formal position on behalf of nhsba
right i i guess the question wasn't
about the bill it was just merely about
the fact that is is it better to clarify
things like medical exemptions and
religious exemptions
so that the school is not exposed to you
know number one you're requiring a
parent to open up a medical chart to
prove medical exemption rights and now
you have to read the people's medical
charts and the second one being
religious exemption you know especially
with this surgeon general pointing at
abuse now you have to go back and see
whether or not it's a valid religious
exemption whether it's a sincerely held
belief and is that a role that we really
want our schools to be in to do those
kind of things is read medical charts
and and determine whether or not a
person is religious enough to be
entitled to a religious exemption sure
thank you for the question
representative in terms of religious
exemption yeah i it's not a school
board's role to determine whether or not
you were being sincere in your religious
beliefs or your statement of you know
religious exemption relative to the
medical record aspect i i you know
school districts do not want to receive
medical information from students but
unfortunately sometimes we have to
whether or not that's a medically
fragile student who's receiving some
sort of special education services uh
this legislature recently passed a very
significant law expanding um protections
for
uh students who have a concussion in
youth sports i forget that bill number
from last year and so there are certain
circumstances in which the school
district does need to get medical
information from a medical provider
concussions special education services
um 504 disability plans or if a student
needs to be out of school for a medical
condition or a disability of some sort
so you know i understand the question
but i guess the larger
the larger answer is that we already are
doing that for very specific needs so
that may fall under you know the need to
look at a medical record relative to an
immunization
is there's at least
analogous responsibilities that school
districts already have relative to an
individual's medical information
thank you
anybody else
okay
erica daniels turn on the pink cards
thank you very much uh no there's
another conclusion
i i will just make a statement that um
the fire and police will be coming
tomorrow um they i spoke with them and
and they uh as you know the trooper uh
that died his his um
funeral procession is today and so i
asked i they called and they said they
would send somebody but i told them they
could just wait till tomorrow there's no
need to do that so i do know they'll the
police will be coming in to speak uh in
general about their rules and procedures
and where there's intervention by either
state law by rules department of safety
rules of some sort
um
is there anybody else that actually
would like to testify
or have a comment for the committee
okay
wow we're done early
if there's nothing uh committee members
any general discussion we want to have
regarding the
presentations that were made today
questions that were asked the answers
that were given
anything we think we want to look at
tomorrow we have um
the business industry and the
medical industries coming in
we've invited the bia
the retail association the manufacturers
association and hospitality association
on the business side we've also invited
the new hampshire medical society new
hampshire hospital association
the board of medicine and the board of
pharmacy
to come in and speak tomorrow and answer
questions tomorrow on these topics we
have a public input session for the
general public scheduled for monday the
8th
at 9 00 a.m in reps hall i'll be adding
a second one on wednesday the 10th um in
the morning i found out that the
redistricting committee is going to meet
that evening and so it leaves reps all
open for us for the day so i'm going to
schedule an um a second one in case we
need it if if we don't get to everybody
who wants to testify on monday
to give them the ability to come on
wednesday to testify as well
but given that is there anything
we want to discuss
no i just want to uh thank everyone that
came today i think it was very helpful
to hear and it was just interesting to
hear that it was very limited
in statute dealing with medical
intervention
i agree thank you and i do appreciate
everybody coming in and providing input
and again if you want to provide written
testimony
or if you go back to your offices and
you realize oh i should have said
then feel free to email you can either
email me directly at my legislative
email address timothy.lang
lag.state.nh.us
and i'll make sure the committee gets
copies of it
[Applause]
but i appreciate everybody coming if
there's nothing else to come before the